yes
what a piece of news so i know talking
about this
usually means youtube is instantly like
did you say those names
uh why did you say that why did you say
that yeah normally we use the fancy mics
for a video like this but the mics
aren't working
but i really want to talk about this and
if it gets a yellow dollar bill it gets
yellow dollar
bill remove we'll see what everyone else
says ah
from even though it's in the title and
tags in the description box
aquaman 2 petition has over a million
signatures now if you saw the video
where i talked about we talked about
john depp being fired from
fantastic beasts 3 and whoever wants to
be like he wasn't fired he resigned
guys come on get real what else would it
have been acquiesce
to their request it's a nice would have
been the most polite
way of getting fired they paid him so
much money to break this contract yeah
yeah you're good you got it
he's got to worry about long-term
repercussions he's got the fan base
support and
also he got a crap ton of money for a
day work you know
um he could probably go star in a harry
potter fan film now
but i did say in that video that um
like pretty early on in it that i think
ah
should be let go and i thought about it
more and it makes sense
kind of why she wouldn't be you know
because she has the victim
title right now also she's not only an
aquaman too she's also in the snyder cut
you know like man there's just so much
i'm already so invested she's already
such a big part of this
but i you know what there's something i
did want to clarify because someone
asked
we shot that video on a day where i was
just like really
kind of out of it there's something i
did want to clarify and some
someone asked a uh a a question and i
decided to reply to it and i pinned it
and i just want to make this clear so
it's kind of a long thing i want to read
off some people wanted me to clarify a
little bit of my stance on the matter
with
jd here's what i said someone said i'm
confused but he kept saying he was at
fault too can you clarify exactly
what did he do i gave a pretty lengthy
reply that's fair
thanks for asking i'm not sure if i
actually did say he was at fault too
however i can see why you phrased your
question that way so i'll clarify
what i wanted to do is really encourage
people to fully research it because like
i said in the video
there's a lot and many things revealed
before the trial even took place
documents audio etc in my opinion solely
based off everything i've read and
listened to this year
for lack of a better term they had a
toxic relationship
not saying it's healthy or okay however
it's common that in toxic relationships
both parties are emotionally and
verbally abusive to one another which i
think is the case with them
some people want to say that that's not
the case that's just where i stand on
that matter all right
however i don't think that equates to
johnny is abuser and amber's victim it's
an abusive relationship there's a
difference
secondly i especially don't think he was
in fact a wife-beater so i said
this i'll share with you where i stand
but first i'll read it
reiterate i along with the majority of
the world have you read this yet
and people taking stances people taking
stances weren't at the trial so while
i've read and listened to so much this
year i'm sure there's still many things
i haven't gotten around to
not saying i think my conclusion on the
matter is correct or incorrect just
saying this is where i've landed
if truly damning evidence comes out for
the public to access that can convince
me otherwise then so be it right now
here's my personal take there's a lot of
and this is true i mean
there's many channels you can go to i
think the top one i would recommend
is incredibly average or there's a lot
of just raw
full-on not not like a clip or something
it's a
long extended conversations and then
even the depositions and stuff there's a
lot of evidence back with
witnesses testimonies etc that strongly
suggests amber heard lied about
physically assaulted incidences
it seems evident she was no saint
there's audio where she admits that
she'll start attacking hitting throwing
pots
vases physically abusing him for really
no justifiable reasons such as defense
that's just one example to sum it up the
court ruled in favor of the son label
him
as a wife beater essentially they agreed
right with everything that i've been
able to read and listen to
i came to the conclusion that i don't
believe he was and that her lied fate
manipulated the narrative
heavily to paint him as a physical
abusive uncontrollable tyrant towards
her
when there's much more to suggest in
reality she was a dominant physical
aggressor
instigator in the relationship again
audio admission that is my sense of the
matter like
i said wasn't at the trial so i can't
say here's everything that was presented
perhaps there was much more to the story
reveal of the trial that we just don't
know yet
right now from the info that i've come
across that's where i'm at yeah i just
want to make that point clear
this video is clarifying that but i i
did think that when i was watching back
i was like man that is a good comment
because
i did not clarify fully where i was at
and
i didn't write that today and then film
this video i wrote that back that day
we made this video so that he could
write the comment and
and create a false narrative that
existed previously
where we're at all right here's what the
petition says amber hurt has been
exposed as a domestic abuser by johnny
depp
states the petition in his 50 million
lawsuit johnny depp describes
many incidents of the domestic abuse
that he suffered at the hands of his
then wife
including one incident where she punched
him twice in the face another where she
shattered his finger with a vodka bottle
and his finger had to be surgically
reattached he will bear the scar from
that for the rest of his life deb lost
the defamation lawsuit as we all know
the petition continues also amber heard
was arrested in 2009 for
i mean yes she was arrested for abuse in
2009
it's a different thing it's a different
relationship i think there's some reason
to factor it in though
i will say there's some reason it's part
of the
history yeah it is part of a whole
picture
since heard's divorced from dry adapt
she has systematically crusaded to ruin
depth in hollywood repeating multiple
accounts
of fake incidences and when she actually
abused johnny i i i've
failed my rule i've been saying the
names but i didn't create it
just go back and put a voldemort over
them about the incident during which he
shattered the bones and giardo's finger
and nearly severed it causing depth to
require surgery to reattach
and repair it her presented a false
story claiming that he cut off his
finger himself
dip it in paint and scrawled obscenities
all over the wall
wow that's a claim so basically with it
concluding i'm
kind of speeding through some of this
they must not ignore the suffering of
herds victims and must not glamorize a
domestic abuser
men are victims of domestic abuse just
like women this must be recognized an
action must be taken to prevent a known
abuser from being celebrated within the
entertainment industry
oh wow wow and it's got over a
million signatures that's that's the big
come on factor there is is a lot a lot
i've heard about a lot of petitions
getting hundreds of thousands of
signatures but to reach that millie that
fast
i mean like guys warner brothers just
from a pr
standpoint fantastic beasts is one of
the most fascinating subjects
to me right now because like mads
mickelson being hired for it
possibly amber heard is going to play
grindelwald
i'm just saying that with fantastic
beasts you got ezra in there
you have the whole johnny depp situation
you got jk rowling
and then and that's a warner brothers
movie and then warner brothers is also
having to deal with
they got the snyder cut coming out and
then in the snyder cut they got ray
fisher going to war with them and ezra
miller's in there
to have a relationship with an actor if
you're warner
it's not it's like there are a lot of
troubled waters clearly this amber herd
thing
is gonna be a detriment i used to kind
of gawk at
um you know petitions i still think a
lot of them are silly when it comes to
movies
seeing that sometimes these petitions i
mean steiner code is a perfect example
these petitions can sometimes have
weight and i think
that is they've been demanding this for
a while well and this is a
and this is very different from a sort
of like i don't like game of thrones
season eight it could have been better
reshooting yeah this is like hey
we're dealing with like real life
circumstances
and also the law and this decision
doesn't seem to yeah like reflect the
entirety of the scenario as we were
talking about a minute ago
so it then makes me cynically go well
i guess they can afford to pay
johnny depp to leave but they have amber
heard just tied up in way too many
properties with way too much money on
the line in
all different stages of development i'd
be
more distracted by her than i would ezra
miller
because now we just live in the universe
where he exists and we're never gonna
who's gonna just who who is honestly
gonna
just watch her i don't understand how
you can
possibly this is such a good position
for them to be in because i mean sure
there's people who don't follow it but
still
the element of you have the ruling in
the sun
case and so now they also have this
metal layer of like
well in certain people's eyes then we
would just be like
yeah exactly like abandoning our victim
uh and
that is ah like i don't know what wb is
gonna do and part of me feels like
if they were to remove her people would
probably move past it relatively quickly
i think they move past that way quickly
it'll become like a a slightly more
notable version of like when katie
holmes got replaced with maggie
gyllenhaal like people will have an
opinion about which one they liked
better but
ultimately it won't be that big of a
deal there was way
less reasons to remove
katie holmes than there is to remove
emperor there's way less
yeah do it also you know amber heard it
i suppose is a decent actress i've never
like been like wow she transforms you
know
i don't think she's like that caliber of
talent i just think it won't be a big
deal and if anything
you just have a really bad spotlight and
and people
i i don't think people are just going to
let this go right away i
like i think like this are from the
knuckle man 2 and i think once the
trailer comes out any i just think that
this fire will burn for a while it'll
burn a while
they'll bring johnny depp back they'll
get rid of amber
it'll be james gunn and everybody else
it'll it'll be a weird frankenstein
monster of responses and whatever's
happening right now yeah
i doubt is the conclusion of this anyway
guys did you sign did you sign let me
know
subscribe click that notification bell
see you guys soon